Now, it's time to implement the diffusion equation in 2D.
Of course, the arrays for the old and the new temperatures are now 2-dimensional arrays,
and we initialize the arrays by putting in a right angle of high temperature.
You may wonder about the order of y and x here.
Shouldn't x be the first one and y be the second one.
We use this order with the y appearing first and the x appearing last
because we stick to the idea of the arrays being matrices.
With the matrix, the first index refers to the number of the row
and the second index refers to the number of the column.
Changing the row mean to go up or down, which is like changing y,
and changing the column means to go left or right, which works like changing x.